deutschland an der schwelle zum zweiten
lockdown viele menschen in deutschland
haben angst dass alles wieder kommt das
alles runter gefahren wird wie damals im
märz
sie haben angst um ihren job oder das
wieder schulen und kitas dicht gemacht
werden
hier ist das seit heute schon im
landkreis rottal-inn der neueste krone
hotspot in bayern nach berchtesgaden der
instanz wert steht schon bei über 200
die ampel auf dunkelrot dienstag 0 uhr
gelten die maßnahmen dass man eigentlich
nur noch raus gehen darf um zu arbeiten
um einzukaufen und zubehör zu gehen
es gibt einen die herbergs verbot für
touristische zwecke
und es gibt ein besuchsverbot oder
veränderungen in den tagen häuser in
altenheimen oder oder heimen um die
infektionsketten so schnell wie es geht
zu unterbrechen dass die werte die wir
die hohen werte die wir momentan haben
wieder nach unten gehen
erst rottal-inn dann wieder ganz
deutschland im lock down
die kanzlerin warnt genau davor heute
mit dramatischen worten hinter
verschlossenen türen die intensivbetten
könnten knapp werden sagt sie dramatisch
nennt sie die lage nach bild
-informationen eine art sos notruf der
kanzlerin was es jetzt daran was gibt's
neues also die bundeskanzlerin hat sich
heute noch mal gesprochen mit dem
cdu-präsidium und mit dem cdu
bundesvorstand und zugegen war auch der
kanzleramtsminister helge braun und der
hat auch noch mal genau wie die
kanzlerin selbst eindringlich gemahnt
hat gesagt wir sehen derzeit dass die
zahlen der infizierten sich eigentlich
pro woche nahezu verdoppeln um demnach
wären wir nächste woche schon in
deutschland bei rund 30.000
neuinfizierten pro tag seine ihre zahl
man kann natürlich jetzt sagen das hat
im kanzleramt schon nochmal für
alarmstimmung gesorgt und so ist auch zu
verstehen dass die bundeskanzlerin den
eigentlich für freitag geplanten gipfel
mit dem ministerpräsidenten noch mal um
zwei tage vor zieht jetzt auf mittwoch
und was wir hören ist dass sie so etwas
wie einen lock down lockdown leitet
zurzeit plant also sie telefoniert
natürlich im vorfeld so eines gipfels
führung das mache ich nur sie das machen
auch ihre mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter und im gespräch ist unter
anderem dass man jetzt darüber nachdenkt
die restaurants zu schließen bars zu
schließen
auch veranstaltungen abzusagen dass man
aber auf jeden fall versucht die schulen
und die kindergärten so gut es geht
offen zu halten also laut unseren
informationen plant die kanzlerin ein
lockdown leid was sagst du realistisch
ist dass das ist wirklich kommt also wir
sehen das ja in einigen regionen oder
ortschaften auch schon heute hat in
bayern die zweite kommune einen lock
down verkündet der in der nacht zu
morgen dann ausgeführt wird die stadt
augsburg die drittgrößte stadt in bayern
die denkt auch mittlerweile über einen
lock down nach das bedeutet also das
restaurant schließt das bad schließen
dass möglicherweise sogar schulen
schließen wir es in bayern jetzt auch
schon sehen
das hat ja die bundeskanzlerin oder
versucht explizit noch nicht
durchzuführen sondern die schulen und
die kindergärten sollen offen bleiben
aber wir sehen jetzt regional schon das
ist ein locker und gibt wohl sogar auch
schulen und kindergärten wieder
schließen
und ja das muss man dann sehen das hängt
natürlich ganz klar von den infizierten
zahlen immer mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren